have you guys ever went to the club and
y'all get drunk and y'all lit and then
y'all get in the car and by the time you
get home you're so drunk that you can't
even because you fell asleep in the car
I found the solution listen up folks
cardi B has a hot tip for all you love
birds hot tip emphasis on the hot
on Sunday the Grammy winner stripped
down to her birthday suit on Tick Tock
and offered up some not so safer work
advice on how to beat the sleepies and
keep things spicy in the bedroom or
should I say
at the club in the bathroom oh snappity
snap snap have you guys ever went to the
club and y'all get drunk and y'all lit
and then y'all get in the car and by the
time you get home you're so drunk that
you can't even cause you fell asleep in
the car I found the solution I found the
solution the solution is to [ __ ] in the
club
like this song yeah you know that song
She's referencing Usher's 2008 hit Love
in This Club
[Music]
that's what you gotta do in the bathroom
the cardi captioned the clip quote I
find the solution for everything oh yes
honey of course cardi isn't afraid to
talk all things sexy time it's a
frequent topic in her music
[Music]
[Music]
and when it comes to her relationship
with hubby offset they know how to keep
the passion alive because you never know
I get a little crazy sometimes back in
February the two went all out for
Valentine's Day really love me
yeah we're talking tons and tons of
flowers people he did that
he loved me for real he loved me for
real you love me for real oh my God I'm
definitely sure oh my God I want to show
this to my mom I need to call my mom
rose petals on the floor rose petals in
the pool giant heart-shaped Rose arches
Rose Arrangements Galore and a massive
pink heart made of what else roses
I was so bad
I'm so happy
I'm so sad
I'm so happy and sad because I don't
know why but it wasn't just candles and
Roses it was Chanel lots and lots of
Chanel
it's so cute oh this actually look good
oh this one match my outfit too who got
this at
oh my God
[Music]
yeah count them that's one two three
four five six Chanel bags this is why we
keep heavy kids
I love you of course offset and cardi
share a four-year-old daughter culture
and welcome their second child a baby
boy named wave last year it's a blessing
for God and leading up to Cupid's
holiday the two got matching body art
hey guys I'm gonna do something crazy
for Valentine's Day with my husband I'm
going to give him a tattoo let me
rephrase that cardi and her man Inked
each other with their wedding
anniversary 9 2017.
not happy so whether it's a hot club
moment Chanel flowers or tattoos these
two know how to do romance right
[Music]